hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com
so i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong
and i've just started to make some
youtube videos because
guys i want to pass the knowledge i want
to show you every tool and techniques
that pro traders use at work to make
money on the markets
so i want to discuss everything here
with you
and most importantly i want to show you
how to do it yourself
so in this video i'm going to make a
complete analysis
of gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
and guys i'm actually doing a few videos
in the same time today because today is
my day off as you know i have a regular
job
and unfortunately i don't have that much
time to make my videos
i'm not sure you've seen it yet or not
but i've just done a video where
i'm telling you guys what i would have
done
during the sell-off and rebound i'm not
gonna repeat it here
but in this video i'm gonna use the same
techniques
that i showed you are working you know
that if you use them
like properly if you have a plan that
you build up
before the price action happens and you
just stick to this plan
you're not losing money and most likely
you're making money
and here i'm going to give you some
levels
again there are rules that need to be
followed
and if they are following this plan
things are going to go well
so the plan is first we analyze the
situation
what happened here we had some bad news
i checked the news
the only thing i found you know is like
just some articles
some fundamental articles like this you
know this is basically some analysts
that downgraded gamestop from mutual to
sell
the day before the sell-off the setup
that happened on monday
those guys that just you know using like
some
rivers discounted cash flow method so
for those who are not aware of
this method it's like a valuation method
that consists of considering that the
future cash
flows of the company are actually
what it's worth so basically you compute
all the expenses
all the earnings you just discount
everything so you compute the expected
earnings for the 10 next years and you
discounted using the rates all right the
rates are close to zero today
so just consider that all the money the
company is gonna make for the next 10
years is what it's worth today
and when those guys you know they do
this they consider
that for example for an employee price
of 350
they need to have you know some crazy
revenue of 17
a year you know some stuff like this and
they just say this is insane this is not
possible we
you know they call it the danger zone
right so the danger zone
is for them the price above which
gamestop
is overvalued and they say it's 45.
it's very funny guys because 45 is my
strong actually long-term
support guys it's at 49 guys so this is
the level we won't
be trading below and those guys call it
danger zone you know i call it
the bullish zone it's where in my
conception when we actually above 45
things are doing well in their
conception when we're training above 45
it's danger zone all right those guys
they don't get it
they don't understand how trading works
that you know it's
about the market is looking forward and
people don't
die you know because they think it's
going to be worth this
in i don't know 10 years they buy
because they think it's going to go
higher that's it end of the story
and this is what i'm doing and analyze
the flows the flows are telling me what
people are going to do
in the very soon future so whatever this
was the bad news we had here
so some analysts say yeah it's gonna go
lower so some people freaked out
and just sold and you know panicked and
sold
now we had this huge rebound so once
again i told you guys this in my
older video you don't buy when it's
going down you don't try to catch a
falling knife
this is a saying in finance you know and
we've all tried
to do it you know when it's going low
it's like minus two for example
i'm training indices so if it's like
minus two minus three percent
it's like levels you consider hours
buying because you know you wanna buy
this dip
but the truth is that sometimes it's
gonna close at minus five or minus six
and if you bought a minor three you just
got hammered destroyed so you can't do
this
so you need to wait for some short term
reversal signs
and go check out my other video here i
had one
and i would have bought at 142. then we
had
this huge rebound all right that is nice
beautiful rebound let me show you
something i'm pretty sure even
the macd which is a very early indicator
would have been lagging here all right
so that's why you need to use trend
lines
on shorter time frame to get this moves
right to get in in this moves before
they happen
here you know the consideration was here
so you would have bought as i said
around 142. what was the huge rebound
reason here's why gamestop stock
sold today let's read let's see what
these guys think you know then i'm gonna
tell you what i think
the video game company is taking steps
to eliminate its risk of
bankruptcy and bolster its turnaround
prospects it means basically that
gamestop are gonna pay back the debt
their senior
uh notes with the principal amount of
200 million all right
so basically they are in debt they owe
money you know because they issued some
debt to
they raise money through that and right
now probably at quite
high rate because this company is you
know not very
secure for investors if they put the
money in it
so probably i don't know maybe between
five and ten percent a year
and actually they're gonna just emit
some shares
you know just a few shares to pay back
the debt you know
200 million is like around 2 million
shares
the total float right now is 54 million
shares i think
so just 2 million more shares next to
100 million and they can pay back the
debt
so of course it's good of course
investors liked it all right
it's very good news it means you know
they're using the very high
price they actually use all this money
that they can raise
thanks to a high level of their stock
price
to actually change a bit their business
model and
you know just clean their accounts so
this is good of course this is good
but the truth is guys nothing that's
impressive you know that basically
they're just going gonna emit shares amc
has done it guys you know from 80
million shares to 400 million times five
right he was discussing two million
shares compared to 50
million so it's like four percent it's
nothing guys
so this is not the news the market is
just bullish
this is what a trader like me would tell
you this was not a news people were just
buying this deep here this is just what
happened when the market is bullish you
know all the good news
look better than they are and old and if
the market is bearish all the bad news
look worse than they are
i use the news just to assess the
sentiment
and when i see that on such news
the price action development is that
good to me this is a very bullish sign
so right now i come back to the
technicals what are we guys looking for
so now we understand that here some
analysts say oh it's going to go lower
and some people panicked fair enough and
then some people bought the dip on the
news that for me is random so we got
back to
uh where we were actually last week
but right now we have a macd look the
macd on the four hours time frame
that is turning green so let me
zoom in you see the macd guys
this is the macd look at the past when
is the last time
you saw it green and
last green only like three or four days
it doesn't happen the cycles are around
10-15 days
minimum sometimes more here it's like
the release of them
and we have just a little bit and it
actually just before the
huge like uh through squeeze and we had
just a little bit of bearish sentiment
coming
back here but we basically remained
bullish
and strongly bullish for a month so
here guys when i see this when i see
this crossover that is the macd
signal given on the fourth time frame it
makes me think
that we're gonna just break out this
resistance so
before that let me show you guys what
we're looking for
what is the situation the situation is
so one wave
second wave third wave we want this wave
to be finished so for this wave to be
finished
we need to break out the level so what
is the level here disconnect this high
and this high once again guys i use
idiot wave theory
to build my scenarios so as you can see
here i was seeing a triangle it's not a
triangle
anymore it's an abc now it's a zigzag
correction
so i'm just adapting and i'm doing this
because i like to see clearly where are
my waves
you can be wrong about where the wave is
going to go to exactly
but it's still the same wave you know my
triangle is a zigzag but
the highs here are still the same and i
still have here my overhead resistance
that is right now
at 173 172 all right so i have one of
them
i like to have many signals telling me
the same story so here i have
one resistance at 175 i have still this
resistance by 175 that i have here i
guess for a very long time
you can see if you have watched my
previous videos yes
this level this level here this level i
mean
this resistance and sometimes support
here it will support is a very important
level in gamestop price action all right
so for those who buy or sell
i mean mostly buy gamestop you know that
you feel good when you are above 175
and you don't really know why i'm
telling you why is because above 175 we
are bullish
right and you feel it you don't know why
i'm telling you why guys because it's a
very it's a major major
support or resistance depending on which
side of it we are
so we have this 175 that we always had
we have the 175 coming from this trend
line so a second one and guys
i told you as well you can go and watch
my videos i did like end of march
i was telling you guys that you know
when you look at moving averages
so here the 50 moving average period
moving average
was actually acting very well as
resistance the whole way down
all right i'm not gonna do it with you
again but we have many reaction it has
never been broken never
sometimes you know it's broken here but
never confirmed we never confirmed a
breakout above
this 50 period moving average and
surprise
look at what happened yesterday guys
we just went right 173 so we have
actually
three resistance level given by
three different methods that are at 175
on top of that we have the macd that is
turning
green and as i've shown you guys the
macd usually doesn't stay
green for only three or five days it's
usually cycles
so something is telling me that we are
done with this
bearish cycle so here the magnet was red
for 10 days
so sorry it's not days it's like candle
so it's like four hours
and so something is telling me that
we're done with this cycle
one more thing of course we have the
expiry so i'll show you this very
quickly
we have the expiry we are 160 so what is
the short interest
sorry here i change of course i use new
when i compute my short interest
as a percentage of the market cap i
should use the total
number of shares available so the the
float share which is 55 million i was
using 70 million
sorry it was a mistake and i have
corrected it right now it doesn't change
much about everything i said
but it just you know let's do things
properly so here i put back 55 million
so right now we have seven percent of
short interest of synthetic short
interest
and as you can see the 200 so we are at
160.
so the shares uh the short interest is
concentrated
at the 800 strike and the number of uh
corruptions we have
the april maturity this is the one i'm
interested in the 16th of april
is huge guys huge but we won't go there
all right let's be realistic
we won't go to 800 so this is dead guys
all right so i can
get rid of it it won't change much
because this had
zero delta so it won't change much the
short interest right now
it's just changing the gamma and where
do i have some gamma at the 200
strike i have 5 000 options
which is not that huge guys all right so
of course there is some gamma but look
if we go to
for example the short interest goes from
600 million to 1.5 million
so it's like around 1 billion it's
substantial guys and this is coming in
two days
so this is what we are gonna see we're
gonna see this kind of
bullish momentum happening if the price
action goes higher so
once again i come back to my technical
analysis
and because i'm just showing you guys
that i have one more reason to think
that if we break this level
the 16th of april is coming if we break
this level we're going to have a lot of
bullish momentum coming from day traders
and we're going to have this bullish
momentum coming from the market makers
hedge funds that are short this 200 call
strikes that are going to need to buy
not to get destroyed with a crazy
bullish price action
so i'm looking for this breakout and if
it happens guys if you want to buy don't
buy here guys all right what would
happen as usual is we break
we retest and we go higher so you buy
the retest guys all right
here when it was time to sell you don't
sell 160 you wait
and when i showed you this guys when it
comes back
lower then it comes back to 160 then you
sell all right you always
play the retests you don't play the
breakouts so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like that button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys